la présidentielle dans moins de deux
semaines maintenant au cœur des
priorités des Français le pouvoir
d'achat la sécurité ou encore la santé
alors ces thèmes sont-ils suffisamment
abordés par les candidats
qu'attendez-vous du prochain ou de la
prochaine présidente vous interrogez
c'est donc le but de notre nouvelle
rubrique parole de citoyens aujourd'hui
Sidonie étudiante à Tours elle s'est
confiée à Tristan recli
[Musique]
Sidonie a 22 ans elle était étudiante en
deuxième année de DUT carrière sociale à
l'Université de Tours comme de nombreux
étudiants elle a souffert de la crise
sanitaire et en particulier de
l'isolement elle s'est retrouvée
confinée seule chez elle et suivait les
cours en visioconférence une situation
qui a fait plonger certains étudiants
dans la précarité comme Sidonie beaucoup
dépendait alors des distributions
solidaires de nourriture pour
s'alimenter alors les étudiants se
sentent-ils entendus par les politiques
et qu'attendons de la présidentielle
lorsqu'on était étudiant nous lui avons
posé la question bonjour Sidonie quel
est votre situation aujourd'hui en tant
qu'étudiante je vis seul en appartement
je suis boursière et je suis aidé par
mes parents pour le logement alors on
est à quelques semaines du premier tour
quel est votre attente ou vos attentes
vis-à-vis des principaux candidats à la
présidentielle
mais ils attendent surtout en tant
qu'étudiante ce serait par rapport à
l'aide de psychologie qu'on peut
apporter aux étudiants parce qu'on a vu
pendant la crise sanitaire que les
chèques psy c'était pas suffisant et que
même maintenant c'était pas suffisant
l'aide qui était mis en place je pense
que par rapport au bourse elle devrait
être calculée pas que sur les revenus
des parents mais aussi juste par rapport
aux situations des jeunes parce que des
fois ils sont pas du tout aidés par
leurs parents et il y a beaucoup de
enfin certains candidats qui parlent de
revenus étudiants
j'avoue que je sais pas exactement dans
quelle mesure ça pourrait être proposé
et ça pourrait être intéressant mais je
pense que oui c'est important en tout
cas de s'y intéresser comment là où le
futur président de la République peut-il
vous épauler au quotidien vous les
étudiants
je pense qu'en tant qu'étudiant un des
points les plus importants à mettre en
place ce serait un accompagnement au
projet d'avenir je pense que c'est trop
peu mis en place déjà dans les lycées
mais il y a encore plus au niveau des
étudiants des études sup et je pense que
c'est un manque parce que il y a plein
de jeunes qui se retrouvent à faire des
études et après qui savent plus quoi
faire ou qui font des études juste pour
les faire et pour faire plaisir à leur
famille leurs proches leurs parents je
ne sais quoi mais qui après sont pas
aidés pour l'insertion est-ce que vous
vous entendez parler dans cette campagne
présidentielle de la précarité étudiante
du monde universitaire et des étudiants
en général j'ai pas l'impression qu'il y
a vraiment de programme qui veut mettre
en place des mesures
j'ai pas en tête des candidats comme par
exemple parler de rebaisser les frais de
scolarité pour les étudiants étrangers
et j'ai pas l'impression qu'il s'y
intéresse tant que ça ou du moins qu'ils
aient compris l'enjeu qu'il y a vraiment
derrière ça
[Musique]